hey guys Dr Burg here I had another
question about what is the best nuts on
a ketogenic diet this might surprise you
um check this out what I did is I took
the total carbs minus the fiber to get
the net carb okay then I added the fat
Gams next to it because ideally if
you're doing a ketogenic diet you want
more fat right and we want low net carbs
so the winner look at this peons 14
total G uh carbs minus 10 four net gram
carbs 71 fat so peons are the best nut
to consume because it has the lowest net
carb believe it or not um maybe you
thought it would be macadamian Nets but
that's seven gram but the advantage of
the Mac andan nut is it has high amounts
of fat which um probably offsets some of
the uh small amount of uh insulin
response so anything up here is really
good so Brazil nuts uh six G 88 G of fat
walnuts give you uh 6 G of net carbs 52
G of fat and uh almonds we got to start
going up to 9 G which doesn't have as
much fat 45 and then we have pine nuts
pine nuts have 13 G and 92 G of fat so
pine nuts are really good on a ketogenic
diet because it's high in fat it's close
to the macad Ian nuts okay then we get
almond butter almond butter has a 21 now
I just want to let you know this is
based on cups okay one cup you're not
going to consume a cup of any of these
but I just wanted to give you a relative
value of if you're having a small amount
of course this is going to be a lot less
okay but I just want to compare um of
equal magnitude of one nut versus
another nut check this out almond butter
21 gram
139 G of fat but look at peanut butter
over here peanut butter has 35 G
compared to 21 G for almond butter so I
would highly recommend you do almond
butter and not peanut butter because it
just has more carbs they both have very
similar amounts of fat actually the
Almond has more fat then we have the
pistachio which is 21 G of uh net carb
but again you're going to do small
amounts 56 G of fat and then we have
cashews which is the worst nut because
it has 35 G of net carb 62 G of fat
which is a lot lower than these other
ones so you want to avoid cashew so if
you're going to have um a nut I would
stick with peons or any of these up here
would be good small amounts so hopefully
we solve the mystery of what is the best
nut to consume on a ketogenic diet hi
guys Hey listen I created a pretty
amazing evaluation quiz down below that
actually analyzes your symptoms to find
the cause the root cause of all of your
symptoms the most likely cause so take
the quiz now and we'll send you report